when joe biden announced the early end
of the afghanistan mission he said this
was no
mission accomplished moment and despite
the taliban's growing strength the
american president says it is not
inevitable
that the islamist insurgents will return
to power it's a sobering assessment of
america's longest war
more than 2 300 u.s troops died in
afghanistan
since the u.s went in to end the terror
threat following the 9 11 attacks
so what did they die for we'll hear from
a u.s veteran of that war in just a
moment
first this report
the taliban say this footage shows them
celebrating after seizing control of a
key border crossing into iran
it was one of several advances made by
the militants throughout afghanistan in
recent weeks
they've been gaining ground since the
u.s announced the departure of its
military by the end of
august the same military that ousted
them from power in 2001.
[Music]
in washington president biden defended
the speed of the withdrawal
saying the us would no longer sustain
the human cost of a conflict
that cannot change afghanistan's course
so let me
ask those who want us to stay
how many more how many thousands more
americans daughters and sons
are you willing to risk i will not send
another generation of americans to war
in afghanistan
with no reasonable expectation of
achieving a different outcome
but biden also argued the u.s had
achieved its original goal of routing al
qaeda
after the 9 11 terror attacks that led
to the invasion he said the decision to
leave
was overdue we did not go
to afghanistan to nation-build
and it's the right and the
responsibility of afghan people alone
to decide their future and how they want
to run their country
just days ago the u.s pulled out of
bagram air base near kabul
the center of its military operations
for nearly two decades
the pentagon says the withdrawal of u.s
forces
is now more than 90 percent complete
as foreign troops depart the afghan
military is struggling to push back the
taliban
like here in afghanistan's northwest
peace talks between the government and
the militants have so far
failed and many fear the violence will
only get worse
once the last u.s soldiers have returned
home
let's explore this with adam weinstein
who is a research fellow at the quincy
institute for responsible statecraft
he's an
expert on afghanistan where he also
served as a us marine
he joins us from washington welcome to
dw
um well let's start with the the the big
question then pulling us troops uh
out of afghanistan regardless of the
conditions on the ground was that the
right decision
well i think uh conditions-based
withdrawal would
have um inevitably left u.s troops on
the ground indefinitely
so it was the right call because it
recognizes the reality
that the only solution to the war in
afghanistan is a political settlement
and that cannot be imposed by foreign
troops
and when do you think in that 20 years
that realization
finally sank in
well i i think among some uh parts of
government and
and certainly outside of government the
realization sank in uh years and years
ago
uh but i think uh both president trump
and president biden recognized
the pulse of the country in the united
states was that they didn't want to see
an extension
to u.s military involvement in this war
and
i think the slow progress in
intra-afghan negotiations
really hammered home the fact that a
political settlement
was unlikely to happen and
it couldn't happen with the presence of
foreign troops because
that is one of the drivers of the
conflict in the first place
but you seem to be saying that one of
the main things that that changed
was the appetite of the american public
for this
uh this conflict
well i think the appetite changed but um
you know
the american public might have been
ahead of of the us government in
realizing the futility of this conflict
even if
the american public are not experts on
afghanistan
um when you were serving as a marine in
afghanistan were you were you
clear about why you were there
i think at the time i served i i was
young i was a us marine
i served in a ruseguan uh province and
i probably did have a bit of an
ideological
view as to why we were there i did feel
that we were
um preventing terrorism from reaching
the united states and we were engaging
in nation-building
activities that were admirable but um
the reality is that
that mission was it it was not
accomplished and there was a failure of
u.s
policy and frankly nato policy in in
afghanistan
it doesn't mean that nato countries
should be disengaged economically or
diplomatically
but there simply is not a military
solution to the conflict that can be
imposed
from the outside and so when i
as i did today i read an interview with
taliban's
shadow mayor in the bulk district of
afghanistan
and he said we have won them war and
america
has lost is he wrong
well the taliban have won in the sense
that
uh one of their primary goals was was
for nato troops to
to leave but i think the taliban are
going to find that they're now
part of a more intensified uh civil war
and the only real solution
that allows everyone to win as a
political settlement so the taliban may
feel they've won
but uh in reality uh they haven't
and i don't think taliban statements
about winning or losing
should dictate uh u.s policy or nato
policy
no not so much that but but just just
being clear about
what was achieved and what wasn't
because there does seem to have been
some some sort of muddying of the waters
president biden saying
well we're not there to nation build and
as as you said you were
when you were there as a young man
taking part in this well that was
clearly
part of what you were what you were sold
um
i wonder how the afghans then feel
because are afghans wrong to think that
the united states has
abandoned them
i understand why afghans feel that way
and some of that failure
is the u.s messaging the reality is that
president biden is in a difficult
position and he's correct that the
original intention
of invading afghanistan was to counter
terrorism and we have degraded
albeit not defeated al qaeda but
i think the united states and nato
partners have to grapple with the
reality that
the war became a nation-building
exercise and we did sell it to afghans
um and to uh the random pile of the us
uh you know the u.s soldiers and and to
the broader public as a nation building
exercise so we have to grapple with that
failure
um i mean i i think the german public
was
where it was supportive of uh you know
in military involvement in afghanistan
some of that did have to do with
advancing human rights and nation
building
and so that was um that that record is
something that the united states is
going to have to grapple with
even if president biden didn't do it in
his speech
and one of america's allies after 9 11
president bush triggered article 5 of
the north atlantic treaty
the united states has been attacked and
its allies rallied to its aid to go
after al-qaeda in afghanistan
so aren't those same allies now right to
feel aggrieved at the way president
trump
began the u.s pull-out without
consulting them and then president biden
set a date for a full withdrawal
regardless of conditions on the ground
well like i said i think a full
withdrawal that was not condition based
was the only
uh the only sustainable forgive me for
interrupting
the time is sure you you've said that
i'm wondering about the attitude of
america's allies
america in this instance appears to be
an unreliable ally
well this is the problem with
interventionist policies on the part of
the united states
the united states forgets that all of
these other countries have their own
domestic politics
a perfect example was the failure to
communicate with germany
about what the withdrawal timetable
would be at the same time that germany
had to
uh seek an extension for its mandate in
afghanistan
um from its own government and from its
own representatives
i mean that's a that's a case in point
of of how the united states was an
unreliable partner in afghanistan
but that's because these interventionist
uh foreign policies uh inherently
inherently create partnerships that are
dictated by the united states
and i think we also have to remember
that u.s
society was fundamentally um
trans transformed by the war on terror
in a way that wasn't true in europe in
my opinion
so i i i would ask our european partners
to understand the reasons for the us
withdrawal
but i certain i certainly wouldn't
excuse the lack of communication
um and the limbo that the trump
administration in particular
put uh nato partners in good talking
thank you so much for joining us uh adam
weinstein from the quincy institute for
responsible statecraft
thanks for having me
now in recent years the country with the
second largest troop deployment
in afghanistan after the americans was
germany which has also
completed the withdrawal of its forces
59
german soldiers died in the mission
a memorial to the dead the forest of
remembrance as the bundeswehr calls it
it's dedicated to the men and women of
the military who lost their lives in the
course of duty
stefan gone is a guide at the memorial
site which was set up in 2014
many years after the start of the
mission in afghanistan
tradition a culture of remembrance and
the use of memorials can't arise
from one day to the next
they have to grow the culture of
remembrance within the armed forces
grows as the mission progresses
and with the experiences of the soldiers
on that mission
um this culture of remembrance it is
growing
but most people in germany have never
even heard of the forest of remembrance
which is far from the capital germans
don't feel particularly close
to their country's military the true
withdrawal from afghanistan is a point
in case
when the soldiers landed in germany
there was no politician to greet them
days later the country is still
discussing whether and if so
how tribute should be paid to the
mission another controversial point is
the treatment of afghans who worked for
the german mission on the ground
translators for instance they want the
bundeswehr to guarantee their safety
since the withdrawal they fear
retribution by the taliban
i'm told that the hunt for allies of the
west has already started in maasai
sharif
we hear people in the neighborhood are
being taken away by the taliban
our local assistants feel they have to
go into hiding
marcus groshan himself served in
afghanistan
now he lobbies for afghans who assisted
the mission to be brought to germany
but the federal government is demanding
that they pay for their own flights
german officials say the country has
issued 2
400 visas in all aspects of our mission
in afghanistan
we were assisted by dedicated and
competent afghans
both men and women who supported us
without them we would not have been able
to do the job we were sent there to do
we understand the responsibility we have
for these people
in the forest of remembrance there will
soon be another memorial grove
dedicated to the soldiers who fell in
mazari sharif
the city where many people who helped
the german mission are still waiting for
help
from germany